- Oh no, my dick!
[Theme Music]
- Good...
- Good morning.
Oh my hair looks dumb.
- We're vlogging.
- Welcome to the first ever Try Guys vlog.
- So apparently the Try Guys are supposed
to start blogging now.
I think this is a
motherfucking stupid idea.
- I'm having burgers for breakfast.
- What's going on today?
Well, first of all, let's
get these hot shades on.
Yeah.
- So we're going to be trying this.
Basically, we're going
to do big video one week,
vlog the next week.
- We thought, you know, we
could probably let you guys
in on our real lives.
- You guys let us know.
If you like it, we'll keep doing it.
If you don't like it then...
I don't know.
- [Mocking Voice] My name's Zade.
I'm on a vlog.
You don't know what a vlog is.
You don't know who [Inaudible].
You don't know there's
another [Pao Brother].
- It's 9:01 and nobody's here.
That's Ned, that's Gene, that's Zach.
Hey look, Keith's here.
Wow, good job Keith.
You're so cute.
- Keith, what are you eating?
- I'm eating the rest of my nanner.
- Is that a second breakfast?
- I had three burgers for breakfast.
- Burgers?
- Wait, really?
- Hey have you ever had
hamburgers for breakfast?
- No.
[Laughter]
- I am late for my dentist appointment.
I'm ready to go fucking
film myself in public,
like a fucking crazy person.
- So I guess today we've got
to find something cool to do.
Hey guys, I've got something to show you.
Wait - hey guys?
- What?
- So he puts the teacup on his dick...
- Mhm.
- And the sheets in the fan.
- What?
What is he doing?
- Here we go.
- Is he serving somebody tea off of his-
Oh, no!
- Yeah!
- What?
- That's skill.
- We have more pubes than this guy.
- Everybody's dick come out on the camera.
- That ain't no half
[Mer], that's a full [Mer]
right over there.
- Yes.
Alright, let's be adults
about this please.
- Now somebody put a teacup on my dick.
- Now that's good- oh, let's go for it.
- Little bit more, yeah.
- 3, 2, 1!
[Triumphant Music]
- Oh!
- That's amazing!
- Ooh, it's cold.
- That was great.
- Now you need to be able
to pull it off yourself.
- Okay, well.
- Okay, I'm going to come around here.
I won't look.
Oh no, my dick!
It's so wet.
[Laughter]
- Not only do you see
it go horribly wrong,
but then you see his dick.
- I saw the full mangina.
- This is what happens
when Gene's not here.
- Do you know what hell looks like?
Being at the dentist,
surrounded by pictures of your own teeth.
- Alright, let's pour
some water on his dick
and get this going.
- Alright.
- You look like a twelfth century Jesus.
- Do you want to maybe
like crouch down next to me
or something?
I don't know.
- Yeah, I'll sit with you.
- 3, 2, 1.
- Oh, ow!
- That's okay!
- Get it, oh I'm so wet.
- It's very little.
- My butt is going -
- You know you did it, Zach!
Look at that.
- "Put a little teacup on my dick,"
and you're a little crybaby
about a little spill.
- So I did it?
- Yeah, you did it.
- Time to ramp it up?
Ramp it up!
- That's gross when you say it like that.
- But where are we going to find a ramp?
- What?
- Okay.
- Oh, you look great.
Very like a high fashion
photo shoot, in a way.
You know?
- Your tea sir.
Piping hot, just the way you like it.
- Piping hot.
- Ned, where's your phone?
I want to send a picture to your wife.
- No, no, no.
Okay.
[Sexy Music]
- Ready?
- Yeah.
- 3, 2, 1, go!
- Well, it didn't work.
Let's get some of these shards
away from Ned's naked body.
- We could try it with paper towels.
It certainly - well,
okay, I guess it works.
That was pretty cool.
- Nailed it, nailed it.
- I thought we were going to do it slower?
- Nope!
- Ugh.
- That's so cold.
- Did you do anything
differently that time?
- Did I do anything different?
- Like to this?
- No, I certainly did
it really fast again.
- [Dental Tools Clicking]
- Eugene has great,
beautiful, sightly teeth.
- Keith, Ned, and Zach, you
guys are a little gross.
[Laughter]
[Cow Noises]
- What are you doing?
- Oh yeah, three.
- No, a thumb is the
nose and the forehead.
- Triceratops!
- Nailed it.
Perfect.
- Alright, so we are ready
for the new approach.
We have the track on its highest.
Ned, what's that tea bottle for?
- This is so I can really
smash it and not hurt my hands.
- But then the tea is going to get...
- It'll work, trust me.
- Okay.
- We are ready to do this.
Really, I'm feeling good about this one.
- [Eugene, From Offscreen] Oh my God.
What the fuck are you guys doing?
- Hey!
- What are you guys doing?
I thought we were vlogging today!
Why?
- Did you not see that video I texted you?
Just, it's cool, just take your pants off.
- Put a teacup with water in it.
- Haha!
- We're going to use this bottle
so my hand doesn't get hurt.
- Ready?
- Okay.
[Triumphant Music]
[Cheering]
- That was exhilarating!
- Yeah!
- So this is our first vlog,
we hope you liked it.
It was a vlog.
- We'll see you next time, Triceratops.
[Dinosaur Noises]
[Inhaling]
- I am the best god damn
dancer at the American ballet.
Who the fuck are you?
No one.
- Alright, let's do this.
- I'm wearing a plate.
- Come on, baby.
- Lift it up.
Lift it up, Ned.
- Yes, yes, yes!
[Triumphant Music]
[Cheering]
- All you needed was an Asian.
- We're driving through
on a Try Guys shoot.
If you like this, maybe we'll
do some more goofy shit.
- It wasn't as bad as I thought it'd be.
- [Mocking] It wasn't as
bad as I thought it'd be.
- [Mocking] I'm sad,
I've got to do a vlog.
- Oh look, there's a person in the car.
- He's rolling down his window.
- Hey!
- That's weird.
[Dinosaur Noises]